Another night of Democrats doing
everything in their power
to avoid telling you what
the real plans are
if the country actually picks
Joe Biden they trotted out
a bunch of old familiar faces
in a desperate attempt
to reassure Midwest voters that
Biden will govern as a moderate
however after watching
tonight's speakers lineup every
American should be alarmed it
was a veritable who's who
of failures.
Each of whom have done immense
damage to our country now
let's start with this blast from
the past I ran for president
in 1976 Joe Biden was my first
and most effective supporting
senator he understands it.
I understand dignity obsessions
rage they determine not only
our vision, our actions
but never that's what we need
well God bless them.
But are Democrats really trying
to hearken back to the days
of double digit unemployment
inflation and of course Jimmy
Carter's malaise now what does
it say about their platform
today now Carter's biggest
accomplishment was getting
Ronald Reagan elected president
tonight's lineup was kind
of a time warp amalgam it's what
it would have looked like
if both parties held a joint
convention in let's say 2004
first up John Kerry is still
reporting for duty with
the eight years of the Obama
Biden administration we led
by example we eliminated
the threat of an Iran with
a nuclear weapon America
deserves a president who is
looked up to not laughed at well
John Kerry is best known for
windsurfing sending pallets
of cash to iranians and secretly
advising that murderous regime
behind the backs
of the president and the State
Department but sure he really
cares about Americans oh wait
wait there's one more another
night another former Republican
I support Joe Biden
because beginning on day one he
will restore
America's leadership
and our moral authority he'll be
a president who knows that
America is strongest when as he
has said we lead both
by the power of our example.
And the example of our power
first his endorsing Biden is
the most un shocking thing
to have happened in the last
year he backed Obama twice
and Hillary in 2016
and he's a nice man
and a patriot who served his
country obviously but Colin
Powell talking about the example
of our power really well America
has turned away from
the interventionist neocons
of yesteryear the Dems trot out
one of the masterminds behind
Iraq you remember the one that
wasted trillions of dollars
and sent thousands of Americans
to their deaths in a quixotic
search for WMD is this how
Joe's foreign policy will be
shaped now,
the race to the bottom
didn't end there former acting
attorney general Sally Yates she
also made an appearance 10 days
in I was fired for refusing
to defend President
Trump's shameful and unlawful
Muslim travel ban that was
the start of his relentless
attacks on our democratic
institutions and countless
dedicated public servants
attacks on our democratic
institutions.
This is a woman who President
Trump fired for putting open
borders above the American
people and she helped
to weaponize the DOJ against
the Trump campaign but last
but not least was Bill Clinton
who uttered the one of the least
aware lines of the night
and that's saying something
at a time like this the Oval
Office should be a command
center instead it's a storm
center there's only chaos
whereas I don't think you should
have a dog about the Oval Office
the matter during the Oval
Office into a mini Playboy
Mansion probably shouldn't be
lecturing Americans about what
it should symbolize he for ever
disgrace the office
of the presidency with his
sleazy political arrangements
that continued after he left
the White House now just today
a new pick was revealed showing
Bill Clinton getting a massage
from one of Jeffrey
Epstein's accusers so I ask are
these really the luminaries that
Democrats think best represent
their party the folks you
Americans want that close
to power again now if so then
the choice in November should be
an easy one but we want to go
back to the days of economic
calamity malaise and endless
wars or do we want to continue
the unprecedented prosperity
strong borders and American
renewal of the Trump era.